[Music]
flying in a plane nowadays is about as
safe as catching a ride on a bus or
commuting on the subway of course that
doesn't stop people being afraid of
flying to some the prospect of long-haul
flights or feeling the shutter of
turbulence are reasons to avoid planes
altogether and then every year there are
stories of downed flights or those that
go missing all adding fuel to that
aviophobia fire take for example the
infamous bermuda triangle that
well-known region of the western part of
the north atlantic ocean what does that
have to do with a fear of flying well
famously a high number of aircraft are
believed to have mysteriously vanished
while flying over the bermuda triangle
their wreckage and passengers rarely
ever recovered stories like that are
enough to make anyone think twice about
setting foot in a plane again and then
there's scp-787
as you may have already guessed scp-787
is a plane specifically it is a boeing
747 200 with a wingspan of nearly 200
feet and capable of seating over 800
passengers the 747 200 is a part of the
famous boeing 747 family of aircraft
these are quad engine commercial
airliners designed to be the safest ever
built the particular boeing 747 200 that
has since become known by the foundation
as
scp-787 is slightly different from one
that might take you from your nearest
airport to your long-awaited vacation
though for one
scp-787 has no known date of manufacture
and no call sign both which a standard
boeing aircraft would be expected to
have additionally the plane's entire
exterior has been repainted strangely
even the windows have been painted over
and the paint was still wet when
scp-787 was first discovered as for the
inner workings all of
scp-787's mechanical components
including its turbines engines and
landing gear are in perfect working
order with no signs of any damage in
fact the scp foundation's researchers
aren't even sure that scp-787 has
actually flown since its construction
the plane's machinery looks so pristine
that they might be brand new with no
detectable signs of any previous use
however inside the main body of the
plane it seems to be a different story
anything not mechanical like the carpets
and seats have decayed over time perhaps
strangest of all is the cockpit both the
pilots and co-pilots chairs have been
replaced with two masses of computer
components arranged to take the shape of
two chairs so what you might be thinking
after all scp-787
is for all intents and purposes just an
ordinary plane not enough to put you off
flying right nothing more than a boeing
with a few little things off about it
like some missing seats and decaying
upholstery well there's that and then
there's the over 500 dead bodies on
board in june 1987 this flight of the
dead was discovered several kilometers
outside of the city of bremerton in
washington state the scp foundation
moved in securing the plane and swiftly
getting it into containment now kept
within a foundation hangar the interior
of scp-787 is monitored for 24 hours a
day surveillance cameras and microphones
are located within the cockpit passenger
areas and even the plane's baggage hold
with recorded footage and sound relayed
back to the foundation the idea of a
plane filled with cadavers is certainly
unnerving and more than a little creepy
but why the need for all the
surveillance after all the bodies on
board are all dead right surely they're
not going anywhere well let's talk about
those bodies how would you expect
someone to die when they are aboard a
plane maybe they'd be thrown around
during a crash landing or perhaps a
sudden depressurization might cause the
passengers to suffocate due to lack of
oxygen under normal circumstances you
might be right but
scp-787 is no ordinary plane and the
passengers on board were not killed in
ways you might expect from any ordinary
aircraft accident referred to by
research staff as
scp-787-a specimens the cadavers aboard
this particular boeing 747-200
all have dramatically different causes
of death some of the specimens show
signs of strangulation others seem to
have starved or drowned other bodies on
board have injuries like gunshot or stab
wounds while further corpses look to
have died as a result of blunt force
trauma a few have even been
exsanguinated that is completely drained
of all of their blood one commonality
among all the specimens on board
scp-787 is that some form of mutilation
has occurred 23 passengers had their
tongues removed a further 73 were
scalped 230 had cyrillic letters carved
into their left hands and almost 500 of
the passengers had their fingertips
removed let's recap what we have so far
first there's the boeing 747 200 found
randomly sitting in a field second it's
filled with over 500 mutilated bodies
and third each one appears to have died
from a cause you wouldn't typically
expect from an airline accident seems
strange enough but of course then
there's the apparitions and noises that
manifest inside as cp 787 which is why
the foundation keeps the plane under
round-the-clock surveillance so they can
monitor any anomalous activity taking
place aboard this flight of the dead any
attempts by foundation personnel to
enter the plane during an anomalous
occurrence have led two individuals
being physically ejected from scp-787
causing severe organ damage and internal
bleeding for up to 72 hours the
anomalies that occur inside scp-787
range from the presence of loud noises
with no obvious source to the
manifestation of strange human shaped
entities within the plane the first
anomalous occurrence recorded within
scp-787 was in 1988 when the sound of a
loud pounding was heard against the
doors and windows of the plane's left
side two years later a male voice could
be heard from the onboard bathroom
repeating a singular phrase over and
over philosophers always run from the
advance thickening treatment in 1993 the
plane's in-flight entertainment system
seemed to be activated by itself the
overhead screen showed a bizarre choice
of in-flight movie colorless pictures of
a deceased man accompanied by a female
voice reading a gynecology book in czech
the same year the longest lasting of the
scp-787 anomalies took place this time
the plane's fastened seat belt signs
spent almost four hours flickering while
the first 15 seconds of jefferson
airplane's white rabbit played on a loop
over the onboard speakers it wasn't
until 1997 that the first of the
humanoid entities appeared aboard
scp-787
this figure was indistinct lacking any
discernible detail little more than just
a human shape standing in the aisles
observed by the foundation's
surveillance equipment the figure was
seen removing an emergency oxygen supply
and mask from seat h43 it stood
perfectly still wearing the passenger's
breathing mask for over two minutes
before removing the mask and
disappearing from the view of the
cameras placed on board the figure did
not appear anywhere else inside the
plane another figure appeared four years
later in 2001 sitting in the massive
computer parts that made up the
co-pilot's chair this figure much like
its predecessor was indistinct in its
features for almost four minutes it sat
in the cockpit of the boeing 747-200
just whimpering softly then it lurched
forward vomiting all over the console in
front of it before quickly disappearing
like the first figure scp personnel
collected a sample of the vomit the
entity left behind after performing an
analysis of the sample research staff
found traces of nitrous oxide thorium
bird droppings and three human
fingernails at present the origin of
these humanoid figures is still unknown
could these entities be the souls of the
dead passengers trying to offer insight
into what happened aboard this flight or
perhaps these indistinct human-shaped
creatures are the ones responsible for
the deaths of
scp-787's passengers the next anomaly
with an scp-780 occurred in 2005 when a
female voice was recorded speaking
through the onboard speaker system the
voice said for your comfort and
enjoyment today pancakes will now be
served please do not leave your seat
pancakes will now be served please do
not leave your seat do not leave your
seat leave your seat please pancakes
will now be served yay
pancakes exactly what the relevance of
pancakes are to a plane full of bodies
is still under investigation by the scp
foundation next in 2007 the boeing's
overhead emergency air masks fell from
the ceiling only to be snatched back
upwards they continued deploying and
retracting for 14 minutes while the
plane was simultaneously filled with the
noise of screams finally the only other
notable anomaly took place a year later
when the onboard temperature with an
scp-787 dropped 33 degrees from 20 to
-13 celsius in a matter of seconds by
the late 2000s the foundation's
researchers was having little luck
understanding the nature of scp-787's
anomalies instead they turned their
attention to identifying the bodies of
the deceased passengers on board through
the use of advanced forensics and
population databases these researchers
attempted to determine where exactly
these bodies had come from researchers
still haven't determined if they all
died on the plane or if someone had
exhumed them from graves before placing
them aboard for some unknown reason in
fact the answer was neither and
foundation researchers discovered
something that no one had expected one
of the passengers was still alive to
clarify the body aboard scp-787 was
definitely still deceased but
researchers identified the cadaver as a
retired optometrist from atlanta georgia
who is still very much alive foundation
agents found the man was simultaneously
alive and well in his atlanta home but
also dead on board the boeing 747-200
the subject was interviewed by agents
and had no prior knowledge of any
incident taking place in june 1987 when
scp-780 was first discovered even more
interestingly he claimed that he never
even set foot aboard an airplane which
his wife and son both confirmed to be
true so what does this mean how could
the same man have been alive in georgia
and dead aboard scp-787
perhaps the answer can be found in a
surprising place
the plane's toilet or to be more
specific the place where the things
flushed in the toilet go to examinations
of the airplane's waste storage tank
have revealed something very surprising
there was one more
scp-787-a specimen that had been
overlooked it is unknown just how he got
in there but researchers discovered the
body of an indian man who looked to be
in his thirties the man who was wearing
a three-piece suit was found to be
carrying a number of puzzling items
including a surgical mask and gloves an
unloaded beretta dt10 shotgun several
cinnamon flavored mints a switchblade
knife an amulet that appears to depict
the eye of horus and a ticket stub for
the return of the jedi with the number
92 written on the back all of these
objects seem to be completely random and
the foundation has been unable to make
sense of what they were doing on the man
or why his body does not seem to show
the same state of decay as the rest of
those found on board there was one item
that may hold some answers though for
some reason this man also possessed a
copy of
scp-787's flight log the log consisted
of a series of coordinates which were
repeated
5478 times the coordinates point to a
seemingly random spot in the pacific
ocean several hundred miles away from
the infamous pit current islands the
island that the famous mutineers of the
hms bounties settled after taking over
the ship and leaving the captain adrift
on the ocean is this location the secret
to scp-787
while none of this is confirmed nor
denied by anyone at the scp foundation
one theory surrounding the area is that
the location is another bermuda
triangle-like location one that contains
some sort of temporal anomaly that
unwitting planes fly through only to
find themselves displaced in time of
course the problem with this theory is
that the man from atlanta said he'd
never been aboard a plane before or at
least not yet it is entirely possible
that scp-787 is a plane that made a
flight at some point in the not too
distant future only to arrive back in
june 1987 by passing through a temporal
breach in the area near the pitcrin
islands sure it might not explain what
happened to everyone on board but it
could at least explain how
scp-787 arrived where and when it did
every plane is fitted with a device that
records flight data in the event of a
crash or other accident known to most as
the plane's black box and researchers
were able to uncover
scp-787's inside a compartment under one
of the plane's seats the recorder was
found within a compartment filled with
toxic asbestos and dried human blood
they hoped that perhaps it would contain
some answers as to what exactly
scp-787 had come from and what had
happened to its passengers sadly not the
flight data recorder contained no
information besides one simple phrase to
be sorry while an inexplicable mystery
scp-787 is at least classified as a safe
anomaly by the foundation seeing as it
poses no realistic threat or shows signs
of trying to break out of containment
the aircraft has only ever caused harm
to anyone trying to enter during one of
its sporadic anomalous events but apart
from that it sits gathering dust in a
hangar just waiting for someone to crack
its secrets and who knows maybe one day
you'll be sitting on a plane that's
taking you to your south pacific
vacation and the retired optometrist
sitting next to you will remark that
you're passing over the pitcrin islands
and you'll discover for yourself exactly
what happened to
scp-787 now check out scp-354 the red
pool and
scp-3999 i am at the center of
everything that happens to me for more
frightening mysteries from the scp
foundation